hello everyone and welcome to a fun game
from 1985 it was a simultaneous
exhibition in Hamburg Germany and uh
Gary Kasparov a world champion at the
time he just became the world champion
uh faced 32 microcomputers so he did not
play against people he played against 32
computers uh which would be unimaginable
today even even if Magnus Carlsen were
to play against 32 computers of the of
the top strength that is available today
as that's what kaspar faced in 1985 he
would lose all 32 games like maybe if
okay he plays one on one against a
supercomputer and then he has a really
really good day and then maybe computer
goes into some line that's a very well
known draw maybe he gets a draw but
other than that he would he would
definitely lose especially if he held a
simul against 32 computers but this was
1985 and Kasparov was very confident
that he will win all 32 games and he did
out of those 32 games he won all of them
and 30 of those computers were dedicated
computers that were their sole purpose
was to play chess and two of them they
had to have handlers or Pro programmers
who would use them actively as they
played chess and one of them here was
Richard Lang he was a programmer and
this is a nice photo of him the other
one was Ed Schroeder and we do have some
photos of this so we could also check
that out before we check out the game so
here is Kasparov playing against um well
I don't know which one this is as the
two entries were the genius 68 000 in
the rebel experimental they had to have
people operating them so here's his part
of playing against uh one of them and
also here's a nice uh even in color
photo of one of the positions in the
board I work as part of his uh I believe
getting ready to gobble up that Queen on
G7 as of course he was white uh some of
some of you might not notice when you're
holding a simultaneous exhibition uh a
custom is that you have white on all
boards so this is one of the games that
I had decided to show you and it's uh
it's a lot of fun because the computer
is is extremely strong and then at some
point it just stops to be extremely
strong so here Kasparov opened with E4
and we have Pawn to C5 by Mephisto
exclusive uh operated by Lang with
Knight to F3 Ponte E6 and now Pawn to D3
because part of um plays a a slow line
uh doesn't want to go into some totally
main lines to to get the computer out of
book because in those days the computers
have to rely on books we have Pawn to D5
Knight beta D2 and now Knights the C6 uh
we have the a French variation of the
Sicilian Pawn to G3 by casparov and
Knight to F6 with Bishop to G2 and now
Bishop to D6 Bishop D7 is by far more
common today but okay Bishop to D6 by
Memphis so we have Castles by both of
them and now Rook to E1 uh we have
knighted the G4 and the custom just
kicks the Knight away with Ponte H3
re-maneuvering the Knight over to E5 and
Casper casparov trades once in the
center Knight captures an E5 and the
bishop captures on E5 and it is now as
of move 10 that this position has never
been reached again
I can Sparrow plays C3 and we have uh D4
now making sure because power over will
be stuck with with the uh this uh sort
of a backwards D3 Pawn not even a
backward spawn it's uh just a base of
the base of the pawn chain so it will be
very weak uh Pawn to C4 and now Pawn to
B6 and believe it or not this Pawn to B6
move uh is the one that gives uh kaspar
of the initiative that he was so much uh
looking for in this game uh the the way
to actually play this is not to go B6 is
to move the bishop back Bishop to D6 or
Bishop to C7 doesn't really matter
because now once Kasparov launches
forward with F4 you want to play E5 and
this will prevent kasparo from playing
E5 uh if you unlock as part of E5 then
the bishop opens up and then you also
free up D4 Square for the White Knight
and then you are in trouble and here
okay you don't care about F5 it's
perfectly fine you can even play F6 uh
this is a very much playable even better
for black however uh in this game after
C4 and my Facebook blade Pawn the B6 and
this just gives Kasparov initiative and
if there's a one player you do not want
to give initiative to that is uh Gary
Kasparov so here he plays Pawn to F4
Bishop back to B8 and now Pawn to E5
like I said this opens up the bishop and
also D4 Square for the White Knight
Bishop to B7 and now Knight to E4 we
have pawned the A5 and now Queen to H5
and now look at this the Knights of the
Queen the the bishop here if F5 is
played maybe even The Rook can get into
the game who knows maybe the light core
Bishop can join the attack can um
Mephisto defend this position well uh he
can he will always be worse but he can
uh he can defend with something like
Rook day seven or queen t7 it is
possible to hold this up until a certain
point probably however uh in the game
Queen the D7 was played and now uh
Sparrow just has a forced Checkmate in
five so feel free to pause the video and
try to figure this out while I give you
a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on solving this a
fairly simple puzzle and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show it
is Knight to F6 with check and now you
have to capture otherwise uh you you
will not just lose the queen but also
just get checkmated on H7 so it's uh you
know both is fine Checkmate is better uh
G captures on F6 and now e captures on
F6 and now the thread is Queen G5 check
followed by Queen to G7 Checkmate so of
course a Mephisto plays King Day cheat
now if you play Queen G5 then Rook to G8
can be played but now casparov just
plays Bishop to E4 and now there is no
defense against Queen captures on H7 uh
Mephisto was a computer so of course it
tried to delay the inevitable for as
long as possible Queen captures on H6
King to G8 and now Queen to G7 uh was
Checkmate you could also play Queen to
H7 kasparo for some reason I preferred
Queen to G7 Checkmate so this is what I
meant by the the uh the engine or the
the micro computer up until this point
played a played a very solid game okay
like I said Bishop D7 is considered uh
Stronger Than Bishop to D6 but even here
this c3d4 C4 and now uh B6 just uh that
doesn't doesn't work but uh if you just
go back like a modern engine would or
even a uh uh any a stronger Club player
would because you know that you can't
allow f for E5 once you realize F4 E5 is
such a huge threat you know that you
have to stop E5 at any cost and you know
that you will do that by just moving the
bishop and playing E5 pretty much
whatever white plays on the next move
but yeah obviously this was too much for
the for the engines of the era and uh I
mean it's not that Mephisto was a bad
program or anything Mephisto was the the
top uh chess playing engine for for the
next five years from 1985 I believe to
1990 it won all five uh computer chess
championships so it was uh the best the
world had to offer because
um uh Richard Lang for one was it was
such a such a great programmer uh but uh
facing someone like like as part of you
can see that it very quickly crumbled
basically it uh it got a terrible
position by move 16 and that's
unimaginable you know in in today's
terms here like I said if if uh like
maybe on a really good day if if Magnus
played against an engine he could he
could get a draw but it it would be
inconceivable for for anyone to beat an
engine I could be wrong you know uh
maybe someone will will prove us
otherwise but I just don't see it
happening I hope it happens I just don't
see it happening uh so yeah that's the
game in a bit of a backstory so hope you
hope you enjoyed that uh maybe if some
of you do have a Mephisto tell me if if
this is about um the the strength that
it could produce uh as I'm sure some of
you have it I would like to thank uh I
love you Sonu Peter giverton Matthew
Benoit Andrea vudelia and Frank plui for
a contribution to my channel I don't
think you'll have to really appreciate
it as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the uh to check up on your
model for suggestions and whatever else
happens in the Chess World so thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day